yeah so good afternoon everyone in this
audience I know there are still people
who want to come in but thank you for
the interest my family here is
discussing in 45 minutes the future of
knowledge and as we have heard already
this morning we live probably at a
historic moment in time where there has
never been as many educated people
before in the history of humankind we
have heard about the exponential growth
of knowledge and the related
technologies that come with it
we have heard enough about knowledge
society knowledge economy knowledge
being the precious resource that will
decide the future so what I would like
to start out with is to ask Randy
Schekman here on our panel how do you
see this enormous potential that's the
future of knowledge has in terms of
making it available accessible and what
else you see as possible barriers in
making full use of this enormous
potential Randy I accept the notion that
knowledge will increase exponentially as
we heard with technology as Ray
described so beautifully this morning
but I'm very concerned about the access
to that knowledge and the misuse or
misrepresentation of that knowledge the
Internet is a powerful force for good
but there's also a lot of rubbish out
there the people believe and embrace
there is a digital and economic divide
that prevents people from having access
to scientific literature to knowledge
and even more pervasively I fear there
is a barrier to the acceptance of
knowledge
that has is to the detriment of the
benefit to society you only have to look
at the current election that's going on
in the u.s. to see the misrepresentation
of science and of knowledge that has
taken hold in a substantial fraction of
the American population indeed this is a
worldwide problem climate change
evolution these are based on scientific
observations and facts and conclusions
and yet they are denied by people who
should otherwise have access to that
knowledge I'm also very concerned let me
just make this one more point I'm also
very concerned at the at the high end
that affects people here in this room of
commercial influences that prevent
access to the most important scientific
literature you are all taxpayers and one
or another country and yet we find in
very powerful commercial scientific
journals that you are prevented from
having access to research that is held
behind a firewall that you cannot have
access to even if you're prepared to
receive and understand it I feel very
strongly about the open access
availability of scientific literature in
particular so even among the very
intelligent most intelligent people
there are barriers to access of
knowledge when you thank you very much
for making these strong points now with
regard to open access we have seen there
is a movement that started within the
scientific community so one can be
somewhat more optimistic that this might
be tackled in the right way but the
points you made earlier about people
having access what do you foresee as you
know pop bilities of making the
knowledge available and acceptable in
the sense that you talked about
well I'm frankly just disappointed and a
little pessimistic
the the principles that take an example
that I'm most familiar with the
principles of biological evolution
I've been understood by scientists for
over 100 years and yet continue to be
denied by people who base their their
views on political or religious
principles that have no foundation in in
science
how can one how can one deal with that
level of access to knowledge and yet
denial of knowledge well just as a
response we see there's a difference
between the US and Europe in this regard
but not in respect to climate change
there still is that active denial or in
Janette the use of genetically modified
organism that's true it varies and I
think there are structural reasons why
it varies for instance in the u.s. the
curricula are set by the local school
authorities while in European countries
it's usually a state authority that
decides on the curriculum so these are
these are reasons that we don't want to
go into now but in empirical I think you
have laid it out very well and we will I
think come back to it let me now turn to
wave for an initial sort of statement we
as an inventor and as a visionary you
have access both to the knowledge that
is produced within academia within
research institutions of various kinds
but you have also access to this very
large crowd of young people out there
somewhere who use whatever technology is
available with startups and you know who
think the world is theirs so how do you
see the future of knowledge evolving
will academia remain the same with the
walls crumble with the walls become much
more porous as they are now what kind of
future do you foresee for these many
enthusiastic young people out there who
want to contribute and you know turn the
knowledge into something that they can
even make the
Dolf well I think you answered some of
the questions your question let me
respond to the comments that we have
heard I think there's definitely valid
issues and I'm also concerned about
people who deny obvious scientific
propositions for which there's a
tremendous amount of evidence however
that that has its roots going way back I
mean when Darwin introduced his thesis
it was very much a minority position and
the scientific community along with
everyone else ridiculed evolution is
being preposterous so we still see a
strong influence of that we call
traditional ideas about how the
different species arrived here but I
think the influence of science has grown
and I wouldn't say this I have have not
divided I mean the act
people say well only the wealthy can
have access to these technologies that
we talked about that I talked about and
I say yeah like smart phones where in
fact you had to be wealthy 20 years ago
someone took out a mobile phone in a
movie that was a signal that this was a
member of the power elite and they
didn't take it out of their pockets
because it was big and and heavy and it
actually didn't work so only the wealthy
have access to these technologies at a
point in time where they don't work by
the time they work well they're
extremely inexpensive we have two
billion smart phones you know kid in
Africa with a smartphone has access to
all of human knowledge it's a trillion
dollars of computation and communication
circa 1970 so because of the 50 percent
deflation rate in information technology
we put some of that improved price
performance enterprise so prices come
down and put some of it into performance
or performance goes up that's why you
can buy an iPhone or an Android phone
that's twice as good is the one two
years ago for half the price and
ultimately these technologies become
very widespread so I saw the I mentioned
that I saw some of these technologies
emerging in the early
80s and I was trying to find a way to
time inventions and look for technology
trends and that's sort of the ARPANET
growing exponentially but it was uh not
anywhere anybody's radar was 500 people
in 1980 and there's a thousand there was
2000 I did the simple math and said wow
this can be a world wide web by the late
90s connecting hundreds of millions of
people we won't be able to find anything
without search engines or will need
search engines and there's more
calculations and saw the computation
communication resources needed to create
a search engine would be in place and
then we heard from guru about systems
like Watson they can actually help us
organize the knowledge we do have an
explosion of knowledge depending on how
you measure it it's doubling every year
two years and you know an oncologist who
specialized in a fairly narrow area
cannot read every article on ecology
because there's tens of thousands of
them so we need systems like Watson
which are emerging that can actually
reads natural language not as good as
humans but they make up for that lack of
reading ability through scale through
reading you know millions of pages
Watson read 200 million pages when in
order to play jeopardy and didn't
understand it that well it might read
one page and conclude uh there's a 56
percent chance that Brock Obama's
President of the United States you might
read that page and if you didn't happen
to know that ahead of time conclude
there's a 98% chance so you did a better
job than Watson at reading that page so
why is it that Watson defeated the best
two human players combined well it made
up for its weak reading by reading more
pages it read 200 million pages you know
I get stuck at a hundred million pages
or more like a which in which way with
this transform also the relationship
between well it's it's the merger of
human and machine these machines are
helping us to deal with this explosion
of knowledge and find the right
knowledge it's relevant to situation so
there are assistants and they're
becoming more and more sophisticated so
we can focus
on the broader picture look at issues of
common sense and reasoning that
computers can't manage yet but they're
helping us to organize this tremendous
explosion of knowledge but I would not
say that people don't have access to it
it's just too much for us to absorb so
we need these computerized assistance to
help us understand the knowledge can I
now turn to Joe in my question to you is
you know we somehow take it for granted
that we know how knowledge is being
produced because we have grown up with
it we see what is happening now we are
immersed in that and yet when we go back
in the history of knowledge production
and in the history of science we see
this is not to be taken for granted but
rather there were specific conditions
and in particular in Europe and this is
a debate that has been going on monkey
story ins for a long time you know why
did modern science arise in Europe and
not in China although the Chinese were
well developed in some areas etc etc now
it's one of these questions that you
cannot answer definitely but you can
circumscribe you know what are some of
the conditions that we're necessary
which leads us then to the question what
is necessary today but first let's have
a quick look back to history quickly and
since I know how hard it is it is hard
John has just written a book on this but
no actually three books but I'll give
you I'm going to give you one but let me
make it let me make a very brief point
which I think will resonate with his
audience and then we've been talking a
great deal about artificial intelligence
this morning I want to introduce a
slightly different but very closely
related concept called artificial
revelation this is a term being
introduced by the late Nate Rosenberg
who passed away a few months ago and
what artificial revelation basically
tells you is that in order to understand
nature we are very limited if we rely on
our senses alone right so our vision and
our hearing and our computational
abilities are all limited by human
evolution and there's so much we can do
but what we can do is we can reveal
things to us artificially by creating
tools that allow us to see those things
that nature didn't mean us to see and so
we built telescopes we built microscopes
to see things that we normally wouldn't
be able to see we create vacuum pumps
and now we have to cook
computers that allow us to do
computations that nature didn't mean us
to make because our brains are limited
but we can fool nature by doing things
that nature didn't want us to do the
great bread sauce that we associate with
the work of people like Galileo and
Newton in the 17th century we're in fact
made possible by these inventions and by
others like the barometer and the
thermometer and vacuum pump a whole sort
of set of tools that were made possible
that made for this breakthrough and
every time you see a big breakthrough in
science the first question you should
ask is what where the instrument and the
tools behind it now you ask yourself
where are we today and what do we have
we have available
you know microscopes and telescopes and
computing machines that look that me
that would make anything that Louis
Pasteur had you know look like child's
play and so we have vastly increased the
power of us not just to control nature
but to ask questions and to get them
answered and that I think means really
at a at a crossroads and that's why I
said this morning you ain't seen nothing
yet because you know wonderful your
master had a wonderful microscope and
Galileo a principal telescope but
compared with what Galileo had with the
Hubble telescope and you realize you
know how much more we can do and so I
foresee science actually taking an
incredible leap forward in the next 20
years and once science does that the
implications for human technology are
you know unimaginable that's it I'm not
clear that that is the good news or the
bad news because we give people a lot
more power we give people a lot more
leverage it can be used for the
good it can be used for the bad that
depends on what we do with it and here's
one final reflection the late Douglas
north the great economic historian who
passed away Nobel Prize winner who
passed away last month once told me he
said jrgen or something interesting in
technology we talk about technological
progress which has some kind of
implication of monotonicity right that
we're going forward as first
institutions are concerned we talk about
institutional change there is no concept
of progress it may be I'll go get better
it may get worse the last 10 years I'm
afraid in many places things have not
gotten better that growing gap between
our capability to do things and our
institutions to guide us to do the right
thing that growing gap causes me to stay
awake at night we come back to that
David I think it is fair to say when we
speak about knowledge it's always is
knowledge for what knowledge for
something there is no abstract knowledge
which just rests per se now you as
someone who has closely seen what
markets pick up what markets don't pick
up how do you foresee the future
development in terms of what George has
said you know there will be this
explosion if we believe you this
explosion and I think in terms of
potential possibilities you are
certainly right but what kind and the
market is some kind of institution are
the markets ready for this how will the
market perform what else is necessary in
terms of regulation what is the role of
the state big question to you David I
think the thing to bear in mind
knowledge is a is a static at some but
it's a body of techniques and expertise
but but knowledge has to be applied
simply disseminating knowledge doesn't
actually get you very far if if it was
just you know if it was just about
dissemination public libraries would
have made that the rich the developed
world you know infinitely educated a
long time ago knowledge needs to be
taught and then it needs to be applied
to specific problems and that's where
the markets become central
innovation isn't fundamentally an
economic activity largely driven by
profit and a lot of the technologies we
see are a function of the profit motive
they don't just fall out of the sky
going back to the discussion that the
prior panel there's a reason we have
drugs for erectile dysfunction viagra
and don't have anti malarial drugs and
it's not because erectile dysfunction
was an easier problem it's because the
people who have erectile dysfunction are
wealthy and these are problems of the
rich world and there's a huge market and
enormous human need would be solved by
developing antimalarials but the people
who would benefit can't really pay for
it and so part of the interaction
between all this knowledge and
technology we have and the market is
designing incentives such that the right
problems are solved right so we spend
you know enormous amount of technology
goes into consumer goods and have
actually very little practical value I
would set a panel recently and someone
said you know is trying to get an
example of disruptive rate of change
they said there is more computer
processing power in your Maytag washing
machine than the entire Apollo moon
program and I thought well that's the
law of diminishing marginal returns you
know it's worthless applied to something
where it does no good my washing machine
is not going to the moon right there's
some you know kind of a misapplication
why well wealthy people buy Maytag
washing machines that same set of
technologies could be applied to solve
real problems in developing world if if
we stop technological progress right now
and just caught up the rest of the world
where we are that would create more
human benefit than the the series of
innovations were likely to experience
over the next thirty years
that are not going to distribute evenly
at all so the and so let me try and make
a practical point governments and
institutions have a real role in shaping
these incentives so for example the
Gates Foundation has set up and
challenge for creating anti malarial
drugs and because of that incentive
those drugs are now being developed
when DARPA does its Grand Challenges and
robotics or in vehicle driving they're
trying to do these create a market where
one is missing to cause be able to apply
knowledge to create technologies to
solve problems so the tech
all these that we will see are not just
a matter of what happens Eureka
like in lab they're a function of what
people perceive to be the profits and
benefits and we can shape those that's a
societal and a governmental and an
institutional choice but to this brings
me back to open access I mean there you
have a market of publishers who are out
for profit at the same time researchers
complain and the taxpayers should also
complain why are we funding research
twice by if you want to react to this
well it's a very serious problem one
that I take on myself directly there
very strong commercial influences
Elsevier it's the largest publisher of
scientific literature in the world they
have taken a very active role in
opposing open access in Europe and in
the u.s. they oppose legislation
mandating that scientists publish their
work in open access journals it's a
problem how did how to deal with it is
very very serious one that I spend a lot
of time on the problem is that two
publishers like like Elsevier Nature
Publishing Group encourage the
publication of sensational observations
that give you an example last year
nature published a paper two papers that
claimed that you could take adult human
cells and exposed them to low PH and
turn them into human embryonic stem
cells this was a May the evening news
the front page of The Wall Street
Journal New York Times it was fraud it
was manipulation the first author was
humiliated from the experience that the
saint one of the senior authors
committed suicide as a result of his
humiliation this was I argue from
perhaps a minority point of view I argue
direct directly the result of the
commercial influence where journals that
are hidden behind firewalls try to
sensationalize work and encourage people
to misrepresent science that has had
I think a dramatic effect on the public
acceptance of science in the u.s. we've
learned from pharmaceutical companies
that much of the research that's
published in journals like like nature
is not reproducible it does not lead to
the development of drugs as predicted by
these papers these this is influenced by
the pressures the commercial publishers
place on young investigators to hype up
their work this leads to I would say two
very damaging effects on the public
acceptance of science so although I am
generally a Pollyanna about progress in
science and intelligence it will it will
rise we will solve these problems there
there is a very serious problem with the
public acceptance of science i ray said
earlier that Darwin had opponents when
his theories were first published of
course all revolutionary theories
engender opposition but they're there I
haven't seen any opposition to the
theory of gravity or much opposition to
the theory of relativity there there is
opposition to science when it when it it
it touches personal and sometimes tribal
points of view and the I am very
concerned about the public acceptance of
science that it's actually increased the
the that the disbelief in scientific
achievement has increased in recent
years he used to be in the US the
progress in science was the foundation
of the future now people can can blame
scientists for all kinds of things and
deny science and it's not just in the US
it's worldwide so I'm very concerned
about this gets us back to the point
that John made about institutions I mean
we see worldwide that the trust of the
public the general public in
institutions of any kind goes down
science is still relatively better than
other institutions in particular the
trust of politicians is going down
dramatically so this poses a question do
we have the right kind of institutions
what is causing this loss of legitimacy
of the institution's we have and what
can science - are we caught in the
middle somewhere there or you know what
can science do to get it right and to
make for public acceptance there where
science should be accepted so the
different issue despondent something
said earlier that the world is getting
worse in the last 10 years that really
it's not consistent with any parameters
you might attach to that the World Bank
recently reported that poverty in Asia
over the last 15 years been cut
something like 90 percent because of
moving from agrarian economies to
information economies we're certainly
making progress in diseases
biotechnology now has various fruits you
can now fix a broken heart
not yet from romance that'll take more
development of virtual reality but from
from from a damage output of the heart
you can now begin to repair that I mean
there's many different examples of how
we are making progress in health but
we're also making progress in reporting
and what's wrong with the world so
there's a battle halfway around the
world we're not only hear about it we
experience it viscerally I think that's
a good thing because it leads us to pay
attention to these problems but it leads
to the perception that things are
getting worse because their information
about what's getting worse it's getting
better now I think in every age you have
to realize a crisis is always momentous
and it happens now in the present and
it's very difficult to compare it also
what people were afraid of in previous
times it changes quite dramatically and
if you say we now have more information
of what happens but we also have a
feeling that there is less distance we
have the feeling we have only this
planet if you
think of climate change so something has
happened in terms of not just
globalization as an economic phenomenon
but also in terms of awareness bit in
terms of the environment solar energy is
trying every two years it's now at a
point it's about 2% it's only about six
doublings we have 10,000 times more
sunlight that we need so I mean there
are there's progress but the Sun
reported as much people are much more
interested but the question is not so
much you know I believe we all here
share there has been progress that has
been made at the same time we also
raised our ambition we want more
progress to be achieved we want this
progress to be shared more equally
around the globe to have let people have
access to it that yond etc so also
something is changing in our ethos I
wanna make a point that almost every
major breakthrough a particular
information technology is really a
double-edged sword and we better keep in
mind and we cannot really talk about
it's just being good or being bad and
let me give you the the mother of all
examples which is that the invention of
the printing press in the middle of the
15th century now in many ways the
printing press had a hugely positive
effect in terms of access to knowledge
to increase in literacy and so on but we
should keep in mind that the printing
press also caused a major disaster in
Europe and that is the printing press
was instrumental in bringing about the
Reformation and the Reformation led to
about 150 years of major internet sign
wars in Europe in which people both read
the same book at different
interpretations and went to kill each
other over it you know and to some
extent that is a little bit what's
happening today we see these sort of
ideologically driven worth by people who
actually have access to information but
they read the wrong things or they read
the same things and give you different
interpretations and so then you ask me
well do you think printing you know
printing press was in Unbounce a good
example I have a good count for example
there because we know do know that there
was in the Islamic world in which was
mostly the Ottoman Empire at the time
actually there was a prohibition
printing presses and so between 1450
when the first printing press appear in
Europe and about 1720 it's the earliest
we know books were printed in Europe in
every language in in in Roman letters in
Cyrillic letters in Hebrew letters in
Greek letters they were not printed in
Arabic or Turkish letters because that
was not allowed and so 300 years the
Islamic world lived without having
access to the printing press and so you
ask yourself well do you think that has
any implications for our own time and
you know I'm not gonna answer that
question you all should think about this
but clearly the alternative to not doing
it was worse than the alternative to
doing it but we also should keep in mind
that that was a very high price to be
paid for this progress but you cannot
blame the printing press for anything
people printing press basically played a
role that you know that the internet or
computer or play today it's a medium
it's what we make of it well and we want
to so you are saying you know it's if we
leave out ideas if we leave out meanings
that people attach to what is a life
that they aspire to you know and this is
a question that I think we have to ask
ourselves again and again because in
some way we are immersed in many
wonderful technological imaginaries not
just science fiction of an old kind but
something that seems so very close and
yet we very often don't have an idea
what is the kind of society we would
need to make it is fully realizable so
I'm saying there is a asymmetry between
the technological imaginaries we have
and the imaginary is about a society
that we would like to heaven what a
forgiving I think there's much more
consensus than maybe your parents
because again the media likes to focus
on disagreements and but the idea that
we want democracy Liberty ideas of
freedom
it's pretty universal I mean it
certainly can very quickly point to
societies and nations that don't
practice these and ways that we find
ideal but that was not the case a
hundred years ago there you could count
the number of democracies on the fingers
of one hand a century ago
I think the increase of communication
with the printing press brought about a
few democracies and then television
radio and computers have really
accelerated that trend it's now at least
the norm people aspire to that and they
claim to be democratic and have freedoms
and and there's a lot of focus on where
it's not true but there is kind of a
consensus I think on these values I mean
there's some very notable exceptions and
we struggle with those I'm not saying
we've reached perfection but there is
much more of a consensus on how we
should conduct human affairs than there
was a century ago if you wish taking you
ahead well you know I agree with rayon
one level there has been you know
democracy actually is is good for
societal satisfaction it's good for
economic growth it's good for
distribution and many good things that
come through democracy it's not apparent
they and democracy has become much more
prevalent than it used to be because not
appearance and it's good for pieces not
apparent that every society when it has
a revolution immediately chooses
democracy as its form of government but
I was gonna say you know more broadly
you know there was a time in human
history when when there was genuine
scarcity there was not enough food there
was not enough shelter there was you
know not medication so on we live in a
time when there we have actually
fantastic abundance and it's really a
question of institutions and
distribution there's no question that
you know that much of the world could be
and should be wealthier than it is and
it's miss governance that prevents it
from being being so not a lack of
technology and similarly even when there
is abundance
it doesn't actually necessarily lead to
you know good outcome so you could take
you know take two countries that have
enormous resource abundance Norway and
Saudi Arabia right both have huge oil
wealth and yet those those countries
despite this say you know just
incredible access to material resources
have managed that completely differently
and in Norway we have it's a very
inclusive country almost everybody works
even though
they wouldn't have to they don't they
have long they've vacations health
benefits and things that Americans
willing either dream about or apparently
don't want but but I but it's a it's a
society that invests in its people that
people feel identified with the
institution's they move it's audio be a
country that has also has enormous
wealth and you know ninety percent of
the private sector workforce in Saudi
Arabia are guest workers only ten
percent of the private sector workforce
are Saudis most of the Saudis who work
work for the government in kind of make
work jobs that don't produce a lot of
societal value and most of the
educational resources are devoted to
religious education rather than
engineering education which is what
Saudi really needs
um but those are two examples of you
know it's not the technology or the
wealth per se or the abundance that
determines the outcome it's actually the
the institutions that manage that and I
don't know how we get from here I've you
know I may be raised right that you know
that's just the natural tendency that
will evolve towards democracy but I
think they're clearly forces pushing the
other direction and so the challenge I
think is to you know there's no question
that we have opportunities and we'll
have opportunities that are you know
unimaginable a century ago but that
doesn't mean they will necessarily be
used well we need to figure out the
institutions that will direct them
towards those outcomes that we want if I
can add to that I think the one
institution we and we heard this morning
one of the panel's one of the one
institution that we must rely on more
than any to extend knowledge and the
influence of knowledge is the
educational system around the world
until that advances and and the best
standards of education are applied in
the developed and in the underdeveloped
countries than the the rich knowledge
that we're generating as scientists will
will not be heard so that that that
remains a challenge of a serious
challenge yes and we also see how the
education of women in particular has
really changed and has been one of the
main elements in being able to bring
about a
I'm wondering whether the audience that
has patiently listened to us now wanted
to come up with a question or two I
think we can there is a microphone I've
been told is it true
yes so we can take two or three
questions but we have no tweets we have
old fashioned questions so please hear
but please be short because we have to
finish on time been here to the right I
forgot your name sorry about that and
you talk about our knowledge extended by
means we look deeper down into yours
into smaller matters and we hear more
and more and we can use our five senses
achievements but my question is do you
think that universe who are basically
diverse manifests itself only through
means of our five senses natural that
there must be ways well we're a universe
is showing itself that we have new means
new senses to register however deep we
go into science ok the question was that
you're right or are right I think I
think was you're right anyway even if it
were for me I think I mean you're
totally right I mean we keep discovering
new things that we never thought a
distance and then we can't see the best
example instead of the recent
discoveries on dark matter which turns
out there six times more Dark Matter
than matter that we can see except we
can't see dark matter we can only infer
its existence indirectly from very
clever experiments that we carry out and
I'm totally convinced that you know a
hundred years from now we will know
things that nobody in this world today
even suspect to be true
and in some sense that's what's so
exciting isn't it I mean we we know we
have things today that a hundred years
ago people would never have imagined and
that's why this is all so exciting and
that's why we you know I'm actually
still gets gets excited about as I never
bid because because the world is so
infinitely complex and we're so small
and we just learning we're just getting
started
and I'm not getting stuff you know I
have I'm teaching in my class and
teaching them history of science and
it's always really good fun to some
laugh at the beliefs of people you know
200 300 years ago who believed that you
could cure somebody with who had the
call by by you know bleeding them and
you know putting a and you know and and
and and all these are funny things in my
mind my students have a good laugh at
that you know these various but then you
tell them you know twin gear 2200
somebody's gonna look at us and our
exercise machines you know and it's a
homeopathic medicine and they will look
at us and a bunch of prejudiced
ignoramus says you know and so keeping
like keep some history the study of
history it's in some ways should make
you feel very modest
let me let me just add you know this is
the great thing about science every
scientist knows that the knowledge we
have now is provisional knowledge will
be superseded extended complemented by
other knowledge and this indeed makes
you humble but at the same time it gives
you a lot of confidence that there will
be others and the in particular
fundamental research is the way in which
humanity is able to expand its its
knowledge and we need institutions and
politicians to understand that apart
from going to Applied Science we also
need to invest in this kind of
fundamental science one last question
over there in the in in the middle
please the lady there was a lady there I
think yeah hi my name is Lena excuse me
if the question is a bit naive but you
talk about the gap between science and
institutions but institutions are
actually nothing but a group of people
who run so the gap is between science
and human beings so where are we going
to find these responsible socially
progressive collaborative collective
human beings to bridge the gap between
science and you know institutions one
influence is the extent to which
scientific knowledge and knowledge in
general is widely available so it used
to be science could only be practiced
and talked about by a small elite that
understood certain you know private
language and have access to that
information there's a tremendous I mean
this the problems are brought up about
scientific publishing I think are valid
but nonetheless says it's just an
explosion of scientific knowledge which
is out there and we have tools to help
us access it and interpret it and lots
of people are involved and there's a
concept of wisdom of crowds where you
know no one individual including
scientists can actually
understand the information but you can
actually have a crowd be wiser than any
of its individuals and occasionally we
achieve that there's also the wisdom of
lynch mob which that's so good wisdom of
crowds but we do have an unprecedented
access to scientific information more
people are able to get involved and I
think that does lead to more
appreciation of their knowledge just
very briefly Randy was a great question
and it comes back to one thing that I
said and has been said today and that is
we must rely on the educational system
to teach people who are in positions of
influence about what what science is all
about what scientific principles are how
science has done what a discovery means
how it's understood by scientists in the
u.s. there was one physicist who was a
member of Congress there are now no
trained scientists in the in the entire
US Congress they're all lawyers are
mostly all lawyers some physicians but
but John not scientist not trained find
it and I I daresay that's true around
the world
so it will depend on our educational
institutions and you know a willingness
of people to accept science for what it
is which I don't which I frankly don't
see now which very concerns me deeply
children yeah I totally do randy said
but i want to throw in one more thing
science depends on ideology because it's
ideology that determines how well the
institutions work in the hands of the
Hitler or a Stalin science can be an
awful thing and I think Ray was saying
something quite correctly which is we
implicitly which is we are the fortunate
heirs of an ideology that emerged in
Europe in the Age of Enlightenment which
game with many of the values that still
sustain us today and as long as these
values remain valid for our society you
know institutions even though they
sometimes tremble up a little bit but
they will continue to be what they are
they really worried about the
undermining of that enlightened ideology
which we see happening right behind our
eyes I would like to I would like it
slightly like to rephrase what you said
I would not call it an ideology I would
call it a value and the value on which
science is based is the value of free
inquiry and this was hard fought for and
it meant people standing on the
shoulders of giants air were standing up
against the church and the state the
absolute monarchy at the time when
modern science came up in in Europe and
this value of free inquiry is something
very very precious and I think it needs
to be preserved and it needs
institutions to protect it institutions
to cultivate and to nurture it so thank
you very much unfortunately our time is
up the knowledge knowledge has a future
but we have to remain a vigorous in
defending the values on which it is
based
thank you very much